foreign
the king and queen consort are welcoming
the president of the Republic of South
Africa on behalf of the United Kingdom
[Applause]
foreign
laughs
all right
all right
[Music]
with the national anthem
completed of the Republic of South
Africa
[Music]
[Applause]
King will await as they watch the great
state color of gold string guards
as the captain of the god of Honor will
state the guard to the president and
invite him to inspect
and following the invitation the
president of the Republic of South
Africa with the King will now follow the
officer commanding and inspect the guard
today it's major Andrew Dixon Dickinson
at the coastal guards who is
leading the president and the King to
inspect the guard and
it's the very finest later on for our
top visitor for the next two days
and the King will follow as the officer
commanding
will take the president down the two
lines of soldiers
[Music]
very often the officer of the God has to
learn a language other than
his own in order to present the guard to
the visiting Head of State on this
occasion
suffices
and is a reminder of so much that is
shared by the United Kingdom with South
Africa
[Music]
the bells of horse cards playing out
quarter past 12
.
goldsmen of number seven company
culturing Gods
who marched from
Wellington Barracks earlier on down
Birdcage walked to take position here on
horse guards
the traditional scene
for these
ceremonial locations as the officer
commanding takes leave of the president
and the King will escort him back to the
Pavilion